this is out of everything we've done on
the show I know we'll get the most crap
for this because we are going to
separate fact from fiction and debunk
some of the biggest Bruce Lee myths and
honor the latest film to have come out
so it's time for a sacred cow cook-off
all right that says cookout cook-off
cook-off the competition at this point
though they're really just competing
with themselves okay so I want to give
credit where credit's due on the outside
as far as what Bruce Lee was there were
some there were some areas where Bruce
Lee had some tremendous contributions to
to martial arts okay we'll talk about
that not amongst them being a great
fighter or being one of the strongest
people's pound for pound or being one of
the most prolific martial none of it
none of that is true and this is the
thing what really bothers me was when I
was a kid and we went to my first you
know martial arts classes they made us
bow to Bruce Lee yeah they did them it
is bow to Bruce Lee and I know that's
just it's just probably a crappy dojo
but here's the thing this shows usually
political but truth does matter and
since this film has come out people
actually believe a lot of myths and
folklore let me tell you what Bruce Lee
actually was Bruce Lee was really just a
popular actor who respected martial arts
who was forward-thinking martial arts
but never actively fought never actively
competed and was about two inches
shorter and ten pounds lighter than not
gay Jarrod you look startling me like
Bruce Lee he's such a bet he's smaller
and lighter than not gay Jarrod to give
you an idea walk into the guy paid a lot
of money the play to the movie let's go
to the first myth because there's
actually some truth to it
myth one that Bruce Lee was the first to
mix disciplines he's therefore the
father of mixed martial arts now here's
the truth Bruce Lee if you read the Tao
of Jeet Kune Do he was very
forward-thinking in his time and he did
discuss a lot of principles of mixing
arts he talked about keeping the good
leaving the bad which he didn't practice
it he didn't train that way he didn't
really actively grapple he would be less
than a white belt but he did talk about
that philosophy and since he was popular
at left morbid
at a time when people were training in
single disciplines so give him credit
for that he thought pretty progressively
and that's what Bruce would probably
claim was his greatest contribution but
everyone else has to build up the
folklore themselves here's the thing
though he's not the first person to do
it if you go back to pankration
which is basically no holds barred no
rules I think other than the nobody it
was one of the original Olympic sports
early on in the Greek Olympics basically
combined boxing and wrestling it's being
a boxing wrestling tony danza was a
serious high-level wrestler and boxer
yeah he had cross trained more than
bruce lee and actively competed show
guys like especially with that swollen
tongue right now you're biting his
tongue burning it with coffee whatever
it is is our game we should have him do
it all the time
there was buried sue actually developed
in 1898 by a British engineer was an
attempt to combine boxing with jujitsu
so there were a lot of attempts to do
this now I will say he brought it to the
forefront in popular culture but he
wasn't the first person to do it however
I give him credit for that
he was forward-thinking yeah look
everybody has to you have to kind of
adapt to what's around you and I think
it's just the first time that people saw
it in the mainstream they saw somebody
doing a lot of different things yeah he
was doing a lot of different things
he'll talk about it more in book well
not an actual here's the most important
myth that Bruce Lee is one of the best
fighters of all time now
again as someone who should as someone
who seeks truth and I encourage you to
this is the most egregious lie Bruce Lee
has no track record of fighting so for
someone to claim someone is the best
fight I mean this is a guy who was way
smaller away he's smaller than a UFC
flyweight that's 125 pounds smaller than
not gay Jarrod okay the only actual
fights of which we have any kind of
proof it it comes down to two witnesses
who are often pupils and and that
there's a reason that it's the least
reliable form of evidence in court and
we'll get to that and they're remarkably
inconsistent so I don't have a problem
with some people saying listen I bet you
Bruce Lee if he'd have ever actually if
he'd have ever actually fought probably
would have done better than people would
okay fine but that's not the claim they
say he's one of the best fighter but
it's just not true so let's go through
the fights that are considered iconic
throught Bruce's life leading up to the
the film the one for which we have the
most amount of proof is
actually Lee versus Gary ohms this is
written by martial arts action movies
and people have written about this in in
martial arts magazines they write bruce
proved his prowess many times in
competition becoming the hong kong
boxing champion knocking out all of his
opponents including British boxer Gary
Elms this is in print Hong Kong boxing
champion world champion any proof no
here's the truth it was an amateur high
school match and there isn't even
agreement over the fact that Bruce Lee
knocked out Gary Elms it'd be like me
claiming I beat world champion and a
Nicholas Gill and judo because we
competed against each other in a
regional yellow belt tournament when I
was 16 years old it doesn't mean
anything and there's no proof of it
there's no proof of the knockout that's
the one over which we have them up for
which we have the most proof yeah do you
know how hard it is for a hundred and
ten pound person to knock anyone out
much less all of their opponents it is
exceedingly different really difficult I
here's another one Lee versus Ted Wong
this is one that really bothers me
because in 2017 a video surfaced they
claim that the only ever recorded real
fight of Bruce Lee in which he
effortless effortlessly it's a lot
easier to do something effortlessly than
to pronounce it flooring his opponent
now here's the truth the truth has
matters this footage been around for a
long time it was an exhibition with one
of Bruce Lee's pupils and I think we
have the footage here of some of the
kind of dance the Glee's fight she did
it yeah and explaining rolly it's that
easy when someone's willing yes
mind-boggling people go wrong they
actually there have been like several
analysis videos with with millions and
millions and millions of ways this was
in the made-for-tv movie I am Bruce Lee
in 2012 people still believe in men
Chuck ping-pong thing with Bruce Lee
it's not real even do a quick search but
this is the problem with folklore and
the consistent lie that remains
unchecked around the cult of personality
none of these things with Bruce Lee are
true here's another one if they write
about Lee verses it was a guy named
Eugene Akashi remember I'm never
listening to this story from one of my
early martial arts instructors and the
reason I'm a I got my ass kicked in
grade school because the stuff I learned
at these classes after bowing to Bruce
Lee my friend and you'll get your ass
kicked
my friend all right so this is
legendarily he faced yet this Ukiah guy
and he beat him down in 11 seconds this
is what's written about okay truth is
there's no evidence about this again
beyond Bruce's pupils so Jess Glover
talked about it and if you read his
account his version of the events he
says yeah komuro was there too he saw
what happened only camera then says not
know I wasn't
here's the thing though they were both
Bruce Lee fans and the problem is that
it was tacky I think his head pronounced
at camera and he said he wasn't there
but that didn't stop him from giving a
story about how I actually heard that
Bruce Lee took your Chi into a
racquetball court and punched him
straight across the racquetball court
it's not at all consistent the guy who
says that komuro was there there's a
reason that it's considered the least
valuable form of evidence in court by
the way this is not under threat of
perjury this is people trying to sell
martial arts books and they can't even
keep their story straight all right so
that leads us to the legendary fight
around the which this film is built so
none of these fights have occurred for
you to make a claim someone is a great
fighter there needs to be some evidence
this is an exercise and claims that
circulate we haven't even got into some
of the silliest ones like he beat Joe
Louis and sparring this is Lee versus
Wong Jack man that's a real name that's
a real name what the film is about the
film yeah this film is of this epic
fight the fight that turn the bruce lee
into an icon if you watch the preview
and of course this is where they do
triple punches and they jump and do
quadruple kicks and they defy the laws
of physics but use their left and turns
it on when they turn right so this is
one of those films it's based on this
iconic fight because it considered it's
considered to have defined Bruce Lee
okay here's the truth about that fight
although most seem to agree that the
fight took place in this Wong Jack guy
lost there's no consensus on any details
and first off him beating one person
would hardly establish me as the
greatest fighter of all time but if you
look at the detail so according to Wong
Jack and William Chen's account the
fight lasted twenty to twenty-five
minutes and that's what's used for this
film the basis of the epic battle it's a
freaking long time yeah but that's not
what happened because then if you go on
to David Chen's account it lasted no
longer than seven minutes then if you go
by Linda Lee's account his wife who
wrote the book Bruce Lee the man only I
knew
how convenient she says it was three
minutes it was three minutes she rate
actually it lasted no longer than she
says Lea pounced on him and pummeled him
to the ground in a lasted three minutes
now if you go by Bruce Lee's account
some interviews he says I raised my hand
forcing him to relent so instead of
saying humbling he raised his hands
which just so happened to be like in a
lot of his films and dramatic fashion
again here's the thing maybe the fight
happened maybe it didn't the Wong Jack I
actually wanted to challenge which lead
to a very public fight after that you
can draw in conclusion as to what this
is indicative of behavior but all of
these fights what's what's so convenient
especially when you consider than the
accounts are consistent is they all
occurred first off with other 135 pound
Chinese men I swear this sounds like w/e
yeah marketing and you know they're
athletes I get it but so assign them all
being with other 135 pound Chinese men
they all conveniently occurred behind
closed doors where there could be no
witnesses really very much like Bruce
Lee could've played him in the biopic so
anyway there's all right let's move on
this this brings us to myth number three
and you'll see this right here in pound
for pound that Bruce Lee was for some
reason one of the strongest men who ever
lived if you search on YouTube right now
you will see ten ten reasons Bruce Lee
could have been superhuman he wasn't he
was not superhuman unless you're
counting the strength he gained from
being on drugs going to the memoirs
[Music]
again ten pounds heavier than the actual
Bruce Lee even had to pull a Christian
Bale machinist you happy Bruce had to
cut way to make Bruce yeah especially
toward the end of his life he was going
down 120 pounds geez so again he was one
of the strongest pound-for-pound people
that lived this we had this up with the
best fighter there's no real evidence
aside from witness testimony which is
remarkably inconsistent now listen Bruce
Lee did some impressive parlor tricks
like the dragon flag is something that
he did he did you know single finger
push-ups which by the way is a lot
easier when you're 120 pounds he's not
even worth of my finger yeah we know 20
I was in middle school but the idea that
he was one of the strongest men pound
for pound okay let's go to the evidence
it's laughable the evidence we have and
Bruce Lee talked about weight training
and advocated it if you read his books
you read some was writing he squatted he
did 10 reps with 95 pounds if you
actually look at his training schedule
which would put it very generously would
put his 1 rep max if done properly well
below the 160 pound mark Bruce Lee would
absolutely be the strongest man at a
girl's pajama party if you like this
clip you're like most of the internet
you have a short attention span but it
was taken from the full show you can see
it in the box playing next to me that's
once a week on Thursdays full one and a
half hour show or you can join the mug
club for the daily show we have to take
some of that off YouTube because they're
monitoring us and censoring our words